[Music]
thank you for coming out tonight to the
interval it long now we're so happy to
have you here this is I believe the 52nd
talked we've given and done in this
series over just over two years
fifty-two talks all of them sellouts
like this so thank you so much for
responding and and coming out and and
being a part of this give yourselves a
round of applause we're we're we're
really excited at the great reception
this series has been and and we're all
so excited this is another talk in our
kind of series within the series with
casbahs the Center for Advanced Study in
the behavioral sciences from Stanford a
wonderful program these are always great
talks that bring scholars from around
the world big round of applause please
for Rose thank you very much all of you
for coming and tearing yourself away
from the Republican National Convention
tonight
I can't promise much except I can
promise none of this is plagiarized
because the only person I could
plagiarize it from is myself I would
also like to show real appreciation to
my two fellow fellows Andrew and Jamie
who I'm just finished these casbahs
fellowship with me and some of you were
probably in Andrews talk last month and
so I'm really grateful to them for
coming and showing support so what I
want to talk to you about tonight is the
genetics of politics which is really as
a body of work that we've been
developing over the last decade or so
that's at the intersection of political
science psychology evolutionary
psychology in particular and behavior
genetics most but not all of this work
comes by looking at twins and the
difference between identical twins and
fraternal twins and by complicated
mathematical procedures you can
determine which aspects of behavior are
genetic which come from common
environment like schools or homes or
families and which come from unique
environment which happens only to one
person although those things can also be
biological like the in utero environment
is a unique environmental thing just so
you have a sense I've done a lot of work
in a variety of different areas which I
try to integrate in the work that we've
been doing on genetics and politics so a
lot of this is combined and I'm happy if
any of you are particularly interested
in any of these topics to take questions
on them at the end but what I want to do
is take you on a bit of a story about
the intersection of genetics and
politics and the way that genetics
influences complex social and political
behaviors I should say at the outset
that most of this work has been done in
concert with my primary collaborator
Peter Tommy's at Penn State and along
with a few other people we've been
working on this stuff as I say for the
last decade the reason this is unusual
is that for the last 50 or 60 years
since people started thinking about the
origins of political ideology and
political party identification in a
systematic way the story was always that
this was socialized it's something that
you learn at the knee of your parent
growing up and you know your parent is a
Republican and you want your parent to
love you and so you become a Republican
so your parent will love you or that is
something you learned in the schools or
from your peer networks you know you go
to Bennington and you become more
liberal or whatever but in fact it turns
out that this it's a much more
complicated story it's not that the
story about socialization is wrong it's
absolutely right it's just half of the
story and the other half is what happens
in our biology and in our evolutionary
history and that's what we've been
trying to uncover it's early days so a
lot of this is speculative but I want to
take you on a little bit of a journey of
how we've been
investigating this so one of the early
studies that we did last two years ago I
guess now looked at the influence of
smell on attraction now the story's a
little bit complicated and we'll come
back to more of it later but the reason
this is important is that if some part
of your politics is genetic then the
most important decision you make in your
child's political ideology is who you
mate with right because your genes and
their genes join together to have
children who have particular kinds of
political biases that are influenced by
your genetic propensities but how do you
know right how do you know even when you
ask people maybe they don't know maybe
they're lying to you how do you actually
know in an automatic immediate way what
somebody else's ideology is and for
certain reasons we speculated that it
had to do with smell in specifically
pheromones this shows you why we thought
this so this is a slide where you
basically can see the extent to which
certain chromosomes are associated and
when it's above you know 3 times 10 to
the 8th where you see it's significant
those are likely to occur not just by
chance right that it happens in a
systematic way
and the ones that you'll see this is
political ideology by the way we're
looking at the genes that are associated
with political ideology this is one of
them and what you'll see is that these
are the things that are the chromosomes
that are associated with this are those
that are related to smell that are
related to olfaction and pheromonal
streets so we have these intuitions
based on these genome-wide analyses that
maybe smell had something to do with the
way that people were able to
automatically determine unconsciously
this is not a conscious process the
political ideology of people that they
might get involved with so we did a
study where we looked at facial and body
both sound we did we taped people's
voices saying
hi how are you we manipulated them so
half of them were just neutral hi how
are you half of them were seductive like
hi hi how are you and we also took
pictures of people and most importantly
we did a paradigm based on the wet
t-shirt test although we didn't actually
use t-shirts we had people have gauze
pads under their underarms for day and
there's a particular protocol they have
to wash their hair they have to wash
their body they wear it for 24 hours
they can exercise but there are certain
foods they can eat that can't be around
candles and other things that smell
specifically you can't sleep with
another person or an animal that night
you kind of can't believe people will do
this for 25 bucks but they do and then
they come in you give it to the you know
they give you the pads the next day and
then what you do is you freeze them and
you slice them up and you do various
things and then you bring in another
group of people and you have them smell
them and you ask those people well what
is the smell like to you is this a
trustworthy smell is this somebody that
you think is warm is that somebody you
think is competent is it somebody bla
bla bla bla bla so what's interesting
about it is there's absolutely no
correlation on all these things like is
this person warm are they competent are
they trustworthy there's no correlation
we ask people can you tell if this is a
liberal or conservative can't tell it
all but you asked them do you like this
smell are you attracted to this smell do
you want to sleep with this smell and it
completely predicts whether or not that
person's ideology matches their own they
can't tell you consciously
but the attraction is there so we had
190 people who used various pictures we
had these voice samples by the way the
voice stuff was interesting we didn't
get any findings by whether or not the
voices were seductive or neutral but
what we did get or asymmetries by
conservatives and liberals so liberals
really don't like the sound of
conservative voices and conservatives
really don't like the smell of liberals
and this is a this is the slide that
shows this that this is conservative
smelling conservatives liberals smelling
liberals that M&F have to do with males
and females so in it's a little
backwards right so this one is male
smelling females male smelling males
female smelling so the people who liked
each other smelled at least are women
like each other smells the least this
was a heterosexual sample I should say
so you can see that there's there's
differences in it and there are
asymmetries but these are all
statistically significant differences
where you can see that these are related
to people's automatic you know
unconscious inference about how these
things work the study was very
interesting when I did it because the
first day I was we're really not sure it
was gonna work and we opened up the vial
and I gave it to my lab manager and she
smelled it and she's like yeah it's okay
cuz we were kind of like is this gonna
gross people out and so she brought him
her boyfriend and said smell this and he
smelled it any threw up like I had to do
this Vegas thing on him to stop him from
throwing up and he's like that is rancid
and I smelled it and I'm like it's not
rancid she smells she's like it's not
rancid and I was like this study is so
gonna work so then on the last day it
was really wild because there was a a
woman who came in it was the last day
which is that I I ran the subjects on
the last day and she was about the
fourth to the last person came in and
she came in and she said what do you do
with the vials when you're done and I
said I'm gonna slice him up I'm gonna
put it in the freezer and I'm gonna do a
chromosome analysis and she's like are
you sure and I'm like yeah I am sure and
she said can I have one of them do you
need all of them and I said yes I need
all of them what are you talking about
and she's like I want to take it home
with me
so is this vial I still remember was 190
that was the number of the subject so
immediately after that she leaves she's
all disappointed she's mad at me and
immediately afterwards this guy comes in
and he's like one of your samples is
rancid dude and I said what do you mean
he's like I almost retched like I almost
wrecked
study cuz I was gonna throw up all over
the floor he said which one is 190 so I
went and looked and it was exactly what
you'd expect it was a conservative guy
conservative woman and liberal guy right
so it was completely predictable and it
surprised even me the strength of it but
that's an anecdote but the data
supported it so the question is is there
a real difference between people on the
right and the left that is embodied
right that is physically in one's
Constitution so I'm gonna show you some
pictures and you can decide whether or
not you think there's physiological
differences on average in the body
language of some of these people these
are from Britain Denmark United States
right so the argument that we're making
is yeah there are real differences and
the differences are more than skin-deep
that they actually take place in the
brain activity this is a study that a
colleague of mine Darren Schreiber did
where he looked at differences in brain
activity in a wrist task where people
had to actually bet on money in a
gambling game and he was able to isolate
which parts of their brain were active
and showing that differences between
activation in different parts of the
brain in this risk task could predict
whether people voted for the Democrat or
the Republican Party better than asking
them their political party
identification now that's remarkable
because asking people their political
party identification is the gold
standard for finding out people's
political ideology you ask them right
and they tell you and it turns out
that's not as good as predicting how
they'll vote as brain activation
patterns so the question is what's going
on here right well there's we have some
indications about what's going on one of
the things that's going on is that
liberals and conservatives really differ
in their physiological reactivity this
is based on a series of studies that
John Hibbing and John Alford ran at the
University of Nebraska some of you may
have seen the gig that Jon Stewart did
on this particular study you hook people
up on their fingers and they get
galvanic skin response is based on their
sweat - how activated they are -
particular
stimuli there's another version of this
where you do it with eye blinks and you
see how fast and hard people blink their
eyes when they see a stimulus and then
what you do is you look at you show them
threatening stimuli you shoot them
neutral stimuli sometimes you show them
I'm happy stimuli so what does this look
like it looks like this this is one of
the threatening stimuli alright and you
show this to people and what you find is
that people who are politically
conservative are much more reactive to
this than people who are liberal who are
liberal are sort of like oh it looks
like a fuzzy spider it's kind of cool
isn't it interesting how the eye is
reacting right and liberals are like oh
yeah I mean conservatives are really
scared right if you saw the Republican
convention yesterday masterful things
like can you be scared no you should be
even more scared than you are no you
should be even more scared than that
right I mean there's there's these real
narratives that go along so the question
is in a lot of studies in political
ideology especially work that looks at
democracy and the importance of debate
in democracy you know the problem isn't
that you and I disagree we just need to
come up with a common compromise
interpretation and the argument that I
would make is that that's not actually
true we don't differ on interpretation
we differ on perception we actually see
different things and we hear different
things and we see and hear different
things in a top-down way that's
orchestrated by our political ideology
our political ideology determines what
it is we see and what it is that we hear
for example this is an eye tracking
study you just saw this stimuli right
threatening stimuli the blue dots show
you that when you show this image to a
liberal that's where a liberal looks and
the red dots are where conservatives
look oops that one I'll get to the next
one in a minute
so what do you notice about this what
are the Liberals looking at ah liberals
love to look at eyes if you ever do an
eye tracking study liberals look at eyes
so much you can use it as like the
calibrating mechanism they're all about
the eyes right and conservatives they're
looking at the threat so they're not
actually looking at the person's
reactivity to the threat they're just
looking at the threat whereas the
Liberals are saying well does this
person actually consider this a threat
or not right they're actually having
disagreements about the literal
perception of the event and we did this
across many domains so we did it across
threatening domains we did it across
patriotic domains we did it across
disgusting domains we showed people
pictures of [ __ ] and we showed people
pictures of vomit those are always real
winners but we also show people sexual
images that's what this one is
and again here you'll see differences in
liberals and conservatives right so
conservatives say that liberals are the
ones who are really you know into the
sexes well it looks to me like the
Conservatives are the ones who are all
about you know the boobs and and the lip
lock right what are liberals looking at
Wow doesn't she have totally great
jewelry I just like I'm telling her joy
I like her hair it's just so awesome
right so it's all about adornment right
there are very very different
attentional features by the way you can
run these eye tracking studies looking
at the differences between men and women
and they're even more amusing so this is
um this is again an eye tracking study
that darker color so the closer you get
to red is where there's more attention
on the region of interest so what you'll
notice here is there's various attention
so what's really curious to me about
this picture is um my adviser Phil
Zimbardo always taught me to be my own
first subject always so I always run
myself as my first subject and then I
always end up being an outlier and
something completely not instructive for
other people so when I looked at this
study the thing that I fixated on was
the gun and you'll know like nobody's
paying attention as a gun it's really
sort of interesting but
you'll see differential attention so
what the Conservatives are paying
attention to are the emblems of
authority the patch is about I'm a cop
right like I'm I'm the Law & Order
where as what liberals are paying
attention to is the person getting the
beatdown and to a certain degree
liberals are also paying attention you I
didn't Circle it but to the the cane
like this is a disabled person right
not a single conservative paid any
attention at all to the cane so there's
real differences in what people are
paying attention to it's not again just
an issue of interpretation it's an issue
of perception why is this important this
is important because it can predict
important political choices that people
make about policy issues so in the image
that I just showed you which is this
same image you can actually look at how
liberals and conservatives respond
differently and then the other thing we
manipulated was the story we told there
was a 30-second narrative so in some of
the narratives we called it a beatdown
and some of the other narratives we
called it an arrest and you'll notice
that conservatives don't change at all
how they look at the image based on the
narration but liberals completely change
the way that they think about it when
you call it a beatdown versus an arrest
why is this important because different
people respond to different stimuli
differently so in other words some
people are much more visual and some
people are much more auditory here you
see in this particular instance that the
reactivity on that is really the
auditory reactivity is liberal in this
which is a different image of a woman
looking at a coffin well where we said
that he died in combat versus he was a
looter you'll see that the difference in
perception changes as a function of
somebody being conservative again these
are things that you can run not just
with liberals and conservatives but with
other categorizations as well one it
like when we run these with men versus
women they're always really funny
because the men never pay attention to
the narration it's all about the it's
all about the image but in these it's
it's reactive based on whether or not
people are liberal a conservative and
how they look at the image similarly in
the sex differences one we had an image
you saw the one with Madonna and Britney
Spears you can see the amount of time
they spend looking at the necklace and
the other one it's a story of a it's a
picture of a soldier holding an injured
child and you can look at differences
here I just want to show you how you can
divide it up by sex differences and that
there's differences in men and women
looking at the child's face versus the
child's body so these aren't just
ideological things you can also look at
sex differences as well although we've
been primarily interested in the
ideological differences again these help
you predict policy preferences so we
have people look at certain images and
then find out you know as people did we
make a mistake sending troops into Iraq
or do you think the US this was done a
little while ago do you think the u.s.
can or will win the war in Iraq and you
can predict people's response to that
policy question based on how much time
they spend looking at particular parts
of the image so if they're spending a
lot of attention looking at the flag you
can see that that predicts their answer
to whether or not they think that the US
made a mistake in entering the war in
Iraq and so on
and we've done numerous ones of these
about 40 of them and they end up being
pretty consistent so there are
particular categories of things that
people care about and you can look at
this again by liberal or conservative
here I'm just listing some of the Apes
some of the Preferences of people that
are particularly concerned with
protection which on average tend to be
people on the right of the political
spectrum
none of these constellations should
surprise people who for example have
been watching the Republican National
Convention so what does this have to do
with genes there was a report a while
ago liberals you know researchers find
the liberal gene that is beyond
ridiculous right why is it ridiculous
it's ridiculous for several important
reasons first and most importantly there
is no such thing right
why is there no such thing why can there
never be any such thing because jeans
aren't that simple there are multiple
genes there are multiple pathways these
things are multifactorial they work in
complicated interaction with
environmental factors so you're never
going to find one single thing that's
gonna help you understand the liberal
gene or the conservative gene these
things are very complex and it's not
just Physiology it's not just genetics
but it's also not just environment they
work together what does that mean it
means that DNA isn't your destiny genes
contribute to these political outcomes
but they're not the only thing that
matters the environmental factors also
matter quite a bit so to come back to
where I started why should all of this
genetic stuff matter with like how you
smell people and so on and it has a lot
to do with assorted of mating a sort of
mating means people mate and here I
really do mean like have sex and have
children with I don't mean like falls in
love with and get married right I'm
really talking about the genetic piece
with people who are like them so you say
what does that mean well it's a
complicated pathway right and that
involves environment that involves
genetics that involves development over
time leading to particular and and
showing individual physiology that leads
to particular behavior in this case the
behavior that we care about is political
ideology but here I'm talking right
right here in this developmental path
about individual DNA which is determined
by your parents meeting and meeting
meeting and mating so how does this work
well David buss who's a really brilliant
evolutionary psychologist did studies a
while ago where he looked at the
characteristics that are preferred over
time by men and women in their partners
that they are having children with
you'll see quite a bit of overlap and
also some things that are distinct but
the question is you'll notice none of
those are political right do you see
anyone saying what I really want to
marry is a Democrat all right what I
really want to have kids with isn't is
you know a Republican people don't know
that about themselves so that's why I'm
showing you the slide people
really don't know themselves very well
right so are we really selecting each
other on politics well one of the things
we know is that it's not the case that
you become more similar over the time
that people are together it's that you
start with people who are similar and
you stay similar it's not the case that
you start divergent and you converge
over time you can see people starting
different and converging over time and
pictures of what people look like like
if you show people have been married for
40 years they look more like brothers
and sisters mostly because they probably
mimic each other's facial expressions a
lot I hate you but but on politics it
stays the same all right
okay so if you know that it's not
convergence and it's a sortation how are
people finding each other if they don't
know that that's what they're looking
for well if you look at these are
long-term people so these are people
who've been married had kids longer than
30 years so I'm not including people who
like divorce that you know seven years
in there's only three things that people
make on long term that are more than
would be expected by random chance
religion which we know is socially
homogeneous meaning it's a socialized
thing that comes from the social
networks you're in political ideology
and drinking frequency everything else
is an illusion it's totally random you
like to walk on the beach you eat dinner
you like to go to the movies it's all
[ __ ] right religion politics in
drinking the rest of it forget about it
true story not that I'm a cynic okay so
we looked at it a little deeper and we
say okay is that really all that's going
on all these other things about religion
maybe it's really that you're not mayor
you know you're not meeting with your
ideal body type that ends up not working
out at all until my colleagues said to
me well of course Rose nobody has sex
with who they have sex with they have
sex with their fantasies it doesn't
really matter who you're with I said oh
so what does matter though is race and
if you don't see that by looking at the
difference between the Democratic and
Republican national can
mentions it's the most obvious thing I
looked out at the convention last night
there's two black people that's it right
so there is a difference so you do get a
sort of date dating differences where
conservatives and liberals that's the
only thing that they're significant
statistically significantly different
with what do I mean by that what I mean
is the conservatives on average in a
statistically significant way are much
more likely to want to mate with
somebody within their own race this
isn't just white people it's black
people that's Asians it's you know
Latinos whatever but who's really
driving that if you look at it is white
men white men don't want to have kids
with somebody who's not a white woman
right you get much more willingness and
fluidity around other groups so although
it's a statistical difference by
political ideology it's really being
driven by white men not wanting to mate
outside their racial background why does
this matter why this matters is that if
you run simulations if you buy my
argument that part of political ideology
is really a genetically entrenched then
what that means is that if people are
mating on the basis of political
ideology over time you're going to get a
put more politically polarized
population right you're gonna get
liberals with liberals conservatives
with conservatives you're gonna get
fewer people in the middle and this is
what this simulation shows is that
across 50 years you're gonna get a more
politically polarized population and you
say to me well okay but like why wasn't
this true 100 years ago why it was
different a hundred years ago is that by
and large rich men marry beautiful women
who didn't tend to go to college and who
didn't tend to be allowed to have
political attitudes of their own right
and so it wasn't the thing that was
being selected for now based on you know
the last two series of college classes
that have come out of Brown the number
one thing that men care about in saying
what they want in somebody that they're
gonna have kids with is earning power
right so it's very different it's not
but it also means you're in the same
political and social milieu so you
actually know what the person's ideology
is and so on but maybe you don't know
what the person's political ideology is
so this
a study that we did on an online dating
platform I can't tell you which one
where we randomly selected 313 zip codes
and we took the first five profiles of
men the first private profiles of women
I actually personally read through 5,000
of them it was the most depressing thing
I've ever done in my entire life every
woman had a picture of herself like this
she was like I'm done playing games what
I really want is somebody who's gonna
take care of me and pay for my life
right and every man was like what I
really want is a smoking-hot chick who's
gonna clean the toilet and bring me beer
while I sit around and watch the game
like it was just unbelievably depressive
right and then after a while you know
you frightened you're 2,000 in and
you're like oh that guy in Massachusetts
he'd be really great with that woman in
Arizona I started sending notes to
people but notice people don't know that
they're matching on politics they say oh
I really care about movies and videos
and we have all these interests in
common and I like to travel and I like
to eat out and I like to walk on the
beach and the ability of that to predict
your ability to have children that you
can raise to reproductive success
zero zero right what's really predicting
it people aren't even selecting on it
they don't know so what's happening if
we know that these long term mates are
people who share their political
ideology but people don't know that
that's what they're selecting on how the
hell do they find each other well they
find each other on things like smell
I'm just why you can spend a long time
with someone online then you meet him
and you're like oh right and the people
you were supposed to meet you didn't
because they didn't fall into the right
drop-down category um it's really gonna
change the nature of evolutionary
development over time online stuff in my
opinion um not that we aren't screwed
enough up already okay so attitudes are
more than attitudes right so this is my
kind of logic of my argument spouses of
sort on social attitudes especially
political ones you pass on your genes
in interaction with your environment it
develops into political ideology these
things are not simple they're polygenic
and multifactorial parents create
environments people self-select into
environments so why does this matter why
should we care about this
well there's one big reason because it
leads to violence and here I don't just
mean people hating each other I mean
people killing each other and we have
lots of examples devastating examples in
the last few weeks cops killing black
people veterans and others killing cops
I mean and Wars right Syria I mean you
can think about the Middle East there's
lots of places where violence becomes
problematic its conflagration in lots of
places where we see it and we've looked
into this with regard to the effect of
certain emotions and the genetic
contribution of emotions to put specific
political attitudes in particular we did
a study on fear and its effect on how
people feel about immigration and I
think a lot of you will be familiar with
a lot of these arguments because of the
brexit vote in England and how the best
predictor of whether or not people chose
leave as opposed to remain actually had
to do with attitudes on immigration what
we did is we said well you know not
everybody's the same and what's really
going on is what's driving people's
attitudes on immigration is fear and so
we looked at people not just their own
assessment of their fear but also
clinically diagnosed and then we did
some genetic analysis as well to show
differences across twins in terms of
dispositional reactivity to threat and
what we found is that the more
conservative people are in fact more
fearful but because we had a genetic
sample so what you see here is those on
the right right they're more
conservative and they show support for
stricter immigration opposition to
multiculturalism they don't like foreign
trained doctors they don't they do like
segregation you know these are the ways
it plays out but what was really
interesting is we found that you know
it's not the case that
Servat if people are more fearful it's
the case that fearful people are more
conservative so if you're scared if you
think everything is a threat you're more
likely to become conservative because it
imposes a sense of order right and a
sense of security a sense of stability
and that's what's really driving it not
the reverse which are the arguments that
you often see in the press so I want to
leave some time for questions but
because I've spent a lot of time talking
about political ideology in terms of
genetics I really want to return to a
very important point which is to say
that the arguments that we began with
about socialization are not wrong
they're not wrong they're just only half
of the story and the other half of this
story which are these biological and
genetic and physiological aspects are
another important part of the story and
these things intersect to create the
complexity of the social world that we
live in and it has important
consequences for real life policy
decisions including war and immigration
and who you vote for and everyday
violence so I will stop there and I look
forward to and I invite your comments
and questions and I'm perfectly happy if
you object let's have a big round of
applause for rose
so so we are gonna do questions and
answers now and I want to let you know
both before we get started with that
even Rosen's gonna stick around
afterwards so if you don't get a chance
to ask your question now we've got a
bunch of time for it
we hope you'll stick around and hang out
and try with our more informally
afterwards and buy her book and she can
sign it for you and good things like
that so we have a question from the
livestream that I wanted to start off
yeah and I've got it right here on this
small device so from from from JBL
so that's obj an anagram for l-like DJ
I'm not sure if that means anything but
the studies is for the studies you're
talking about seem to focus on left and
right and and JBL is asking what about
other aspects is it just what about
libertarians or folks that would
identify or be be identified in
different ways what can you say about
that and that's a really really
important question and actually with the
majority of the studies that we're doing
we're looking at the world spectrum of
political behavior from left and right
meaning from communist to fascist
so not actually Republicans and
Democrats in the world political
spectrum Republicans and Democrats in
the United States context are this far
apart they're the same thing there
called liberals right in the world
political spectrum there in the middle
why is that the case because they both
believe in things like private property
capitalism democracy you know
individualism both those parties believe
in those things as fundamental core
constituent aspects of the government
and so they're actually from a you know
political theory standpoint kind of
indistinguishable but many of the
studies that we've done have the ones
that I've talked about today have been
more closely looking at Republicans and
Democrats in the American context but
we've done other studies that look at
world contexts that we have another
study where we've looked at five
continents over 50 years looking at the
world spectrum from communist to
fascists showing
consistency in certain kinds of
attitudes between those on the left and
those on the right over long periods of
time and quite large spatial regions
those topics tend to be things like sex
and reproduction which differ reliably
between the left and the right resource
allocation think about that in terms of
things like welfare and also in group
protection and out group discrimination
not just things like immigration but war
you know defense draft you know those
kinds of topics and let me just follow
up a little bit on that and by the way
we so Rio has a microphone so if you
want to ask a question just raise your
hand and she'll get the mic to you to
follow up in just a second so to follow
up on that so we're in the midst of the
conservative nothing seems more at odds
than when it's convention season right
so so taking your point that we're all
in a liberal democratic kind of context
here how are how would you advise us to
understand both what's happening here
and what as you pointed out is happening
in other countries is is are the poles
getting more charged or further apart is
that something that's is is more seen
through the media than then is reality
are we getting more fascistic is that
really happening or is that just sort of
a dynamic we seem to be observing but
may not be real or do you do you have an
opinion on that I think that what you do
see and I showed it a little bit in the
simulation slide is I do think that
we're getting more polarized so that you
know Democrats and Republicans are
moving a little bit more this way but
still within a liberal context it's
still hard to imagine you know I mean
Bernie Sanders came close to having a
more socialist thing but I mean he
wasn't saying let's eliminate the
military let's you know completely
socialize
all aspects of you know civil society so
I mean it's very hard to imagine
somebody with that kind of argument
getting much traction or frankly someone
you know completely on the right saying
okay let's get rid of democracy
gonna be run by a military you know
we're gonna put you know some version of
you know Adorno in charge and and we're
all gonna be down with that right
they're better at running the war than
the civilians anyway so it's okay it's
very hard to imagine I mean you get
political leaders who used to be in the
military like Dwight Eisenhower who can
then run but that's once they're
civilians right the civilian control of
the military is old and deep in American
culture and an important given what
happened just in Turkey like you can see
that you know there's differences in
that so I do think you see increasing
polarization over time I'd argue that in
part that's a result of this genetic
assorted of meaning on political
ideology but in a world spectrum I still
I don't see it you know we're not quite
you know in a place where either a true
communist or a true fascist is likely to
win the majority of the population and
even now you know we can be very
concerned about you know or crack jokes
about what the Republican National
Convention is doing now but you know if
you run the polls it's still not you
know it's very close right it's it's
50/50 it's not 70/30 so there's still
contention all right do we have right
here in the second round or there we go
there you go so I found the slide
showing the two police officers having
the interaction with the man on the
ground very interesting have you done
any study about how that affects
people's accuracy in let's say looking
at a film of an incident and comparing
that to yet in terms of what actually
happened and I think that that's a
really important thing to do but the
problem is is that the technology of
being able to do eye tracking on moving
video is very difficult
statistically complicated and
unspeakably expensive so if somebody
wants to give me an enormous grant but
if the really what's prevented us from
conceptually you're absolutely right but
what's prevented us is really
technological and financial limitations
but that is the really interesting
question like will it affect how they
subsequently view later elements of you
know a narrative illustration and I
think the reason
like when I think about that the reason
I think that's important is that
narrative is really how you do
recruitment for things like jihadist
groups or you know right-wing Christian
groups I mean it doesn't matter but any
kind of group that you're working using
online recruitment if you capture
somebody initially how is it that the
narrative develops in a way that compels
them and that's a really important part
of it and and I don't think we have very
good work on that now mostly because of
the technological limitations we had a
question on the second or yeah there we
go
can we trick the fearful to flock
towards the liberal infants on the
Librium give people valium you know put
it in the water like like you use with
but without drugging them can we can we
trick them through political messaging
and re articulating theories to be able
to attract the fearful into a more
liberal policy so I have a couple of
responses I mean obviously the one about
drugging them is a joke I really didn't
mean it like fluoride but you know I do
really believe that better funding for
mental healthcare would make a really
big difference in this country and lots
of domains including reducing fear and I
think it's not accidental that the
Republicans don't want to fund that and
not to be paranoid I think that the
problem with overcoming fear is that
evolutionarily we're programmed to give
more attention to threats because that's
how we survive there are very very
there's a lot of things where we have
one trial learning if you eat a food
that makes you really sick or alcohol
that makes you really really sick you're
just not going to really want to eat
that again in the future because it's
associated with that sickness there are
very very few positive things in life
and where there's reinforcement
reproductions like the only one of them
right like sex that's it
everything else is kind of a downer
right I mean like when you think about
it evolutionarily and so it's very
difficult to imagine a positive message
Andrew could say a lot more about hope
than I can but it's very difficult to
overcome fear with hope right because
you know the the imaging that you have
around what could potentially it's it's
infinite to think about the ways in
which your life could go bad but to
think about the ways it could be really
great it's more limited right there's an
asymmetry to that and there's
evolutionary important reasons for there
to be an asymmetry that means it's very
difficult to overcome doesn't mean we
shouldn't try but it's very difficult to
capture people's attention and the media
makes money out of catching people's
attention
and so they're not gonna want to run a
story that's only gonna get a million
people to watch it versus twenty million
people who like them you know if it
bleeds it leads right you you want that
kind of attention and and our
attentional system works that way for
good reason it's just that in any modern
environment it can get us into systemic
and predictable trouble but also saves
our lives right so it's complicated but
it's a very important and good question
and and my answer with a lot of these
things is unusual you know when I just
had to give a talk for the Department of
Defense and they said well where would
you put your money and I said maternal
nutrition you know I mean if you
actually make sure that people in utero
come to believe and you know chemically
that they're in entering the world of
abundance and not a world of deprivation
you're gonna have a really different
group of people you can imagine how well
that went over alright and why don't you
find someone in the back of the room I'm
gonna give you the microphone here in a
second but just to touch on you you
mentioned briefly that sort of
evolutionary perspective and we talked a
little bit it wasn't the focus of your
talk but we've talked a little bit more
about how the underlying impulse is
what's being expressed now in these
cultural issues here whether it's
transgender bathrooms or you know
another topic of the day can you say a
little bit more about how that traces
back to kind of the long now of the the
evolutionary impulses yeah so there's a
difference between these longstanding
motives that are evolutionarily
incentivised and what we think of as the
issues of the day
so how I've come to think about it by
looking at this work over a long period
of time is the issues that you can
imagine made a difference for whether or
not you could successfully raise your
children to have children of their own
fall into these basic categories sex and
reproduction and it's not just about
your own right it's about your desire to
control other people's behavior around
this it's not good enough that like I
have mu morality about what kind of
sexual behavior I'm going to engage in
or not but I have very clear ideas about
how you should do it right that's the
part that that is very interesting
because that turns it from personal into
political right so sex and reproduction
resource allocation that means things
like in an issue of the day it might
look like welfare but there might be a
different point in time where it looks
like something else you know it doesn't
have to necessarily be welfare think
about sex and reproduction you know
there's lots of ways you know in the
18th century it was all about you know
pornography or you could imagine it
being about prostitution and today it's
about transit under bathrooms the
specific issue may differ but it's
tapping into the same latent underlying
variable right and the third one would
be this issue about in-group protection
and out-group defense war immigration
you know you can think about it chain
war is pretty constant I actually have a
really fundamental belief that we learn
to cooperate in order to be able to
engage in combat more successfully
there's some debate around that but you
know I'm all over that part of it I
don't think it's Peace Love and the
bombs will go away but you know there's
debate about that so you know I think
that there's these these really pretty
basic underlying issues you can find
them over time you can find them over
space but the issue of the day the way
it may manifest its going to change
based on cultural factors and based on
technology and a whole bunch of other
things that may change over time and I
know Jamie's going to give an even way
more brilliant talk about this later
than I can but these evolutionary things
it's not every issue that's going to
have this impact
it's the issues where you can imagine
that the successful resolution of that
an adaptive problem leads to you know
perceptually different outcomes and your
ability to successfully raise children
to their own reproductive capacity thank
you I really appreciate your findings
you know the the primal drivers of smell
but that is still so powerful my hope
has always been that education would be
the inoculation against tribalism so
education in terms of critical thinking
skills recognition of a cognitive
dissonance and the development of
logical argumentation so I'm a little
concerned now based on your findings
what your take on that is and that
relates certainly to an earlier question
that you that you address but I'd love
to hear your your your thoughts on that
what are the odds education matters but
I would call it a necessary but
completely insufficient factor and the
answer I'm gonna give is slightly
different than the topic of that I've
been talking about but I've spent the
better part of the last 15 years
studying practices of polygamy around
the world which is where one man has
multiple wives and the corollary of that
is Polly and journey when you know one
woman has multiple husbands it's rare it
never causes a problem the I mean it's
really rare Nepal you know a few random
places but it's really pretty rare but
polygamy causes just an inordinate
amount of consequences that are negative
for women and children and also for
about 50% of men you know reduces
education you know increases rates of
sex trafficking female genital
mutilation reduces longevity for men and
women increases maternal mortality
reduces interbirth interval causes all
kinds of I mean like you know it's just
everything right and when you look at it
in places where it's really endemic like
Africa
and really well-meaning people from the
World Bank or a liberal go in and
they're just like teach women to read
you know give them micro accounts it'll
all be great doesn't do [ __ ] you make
polygamy illegal and all of a sudden
everything changes you get economic
development you get children living
longer you reduce child mortality by 22
percent I mean it's like a one cause
factor but like try to get those
cultures those communities those laws
those tribal networks to agree to that
when controlling female productive and
reproductive capacity isn't the basis
not only of their status but their
wealth good luck right when I look at
Syria and the Middle East and what's
going on there yes there's a lot of
political stuff going on but what I see
isn't that that's all about male
dominance hierarchies and the desire to
continue to control female productive
and reproductive capacity and that's
what they're fighting against and that
is the east/west thing you can lay oil
on top of it and everything else but
that's really what it comes down to
that's what they're fighting for that
way of life and that's that's the place
where I'm gonna say that's worth
fighting for you know you don't want
slavery right I mean of anybody about
anybody and it's not you know the
problem with these is you think it's bad
for women and it's good for men that's
not true it's really bad for men because
in polygamous cultures 50% of men can't
find reproductive access they can't get
wise women to have children with so what
do they do they fight right and the
government's know they fight and so the
government's like well better you fight
them than me I don't want to be
decapitated by you so I'm gonna form an
army and fight you so that I can kill
all these surplus men preserve my
hierarchy and I don't care who else I'm
gonna kill because as long as it's not
me right Assad as long as it's not me
I'm down with it right so that's you
know it's a very unusual way to look at
it Richard Wrangham
ideas right these aren't mine but I
really do believe you know we we have a
database that we've spent the last
fifteen years putting up on the web
called women stats org any of you can go
up to it as long
free on the web we have about 320
variables now for each of 170 countries
on facts related to women and children
and you can pull it down either by
country or by topic
and you start poking around in that and
it's pretty convincing
reowww do you have another great there
we go please first of all this is a
wonderful talk I come here for a
thought-provoking talks and this is
completely blown my mind it's been
awesome so yes thank you I thought the
place that you started was really
interesting of the correlation between
olfactory compatibility and political
compatibility and I just couldn't figure
out how did you Intuit that place to
start and could you just say a bit more
about that the place to start it's a
sort of long complicated story the smell
the smell study came late in a lot of
the work that we've been doing on
genetics so I don't mean to imply in any
way shape or form that this is where I
started and where I'm going from this by
the way is taste my next study is really
going to be about taste because I think
that we undervalue somatic realities you
say to me how are you going to do that
well that's what kissing is about
assessing genetic fitness so I would
love a copy of that study for the way
I've done it yet but by the way I so
know what's going to turn out and it
will be the first study in my life where
I'm not my own first subject
so this is how we intuited I'm gonna go
into a little bit more detail because
you asked um as I said we've done these
a number of studies over a period of
time and the earlier studies were really
looking at genome-wide Association for
political ideology to say is there a
genetic difference on political ideology
and here I want to be really really
clear because of the earlier question
from the person online I really don't
mean political party identification I
don't mean Republican and Democrat I
mean liberal and conservative in the
well actually you know communist and
fascist in the world sense and when you
get a lot of those people and when I say
a lot these studies involve a hundred
thousand people or more these are not
trivial numbers of people and they often
involve twins and when you look at them
you can run for you know each chromosome
and here you see you know chromosome 1
through 22 and we know from other
people's work that's not about politics
in general what each of these
chromosomes tap into because these are
very large studies and extremely small
effects each little genetic thing is
very small and that's why you need
hundreds of thousands of people that's
why a lot of this work has only been
done recently is because you know as
recently as ten years ago it would take
you two weeks to run one person's genome
right now you can do many many hundred a
day but that's why the the field is
moving much more quickly now because the
effects are small there's gonna be a lot
of random noise so the standard cutoff
and this is in disease it's in all kinds
of work it's not just the kind of work
we do the the idea is like okay if it's
above you know 2 times 10 to the 8th
maybe but if it's above 3 that
something's really going on so when we
took all the earlier studies we've done
on political ideology and ran them to
see what things are associated and above
this cutoff point for significance with
political ideology starting dustbowl
empiricism we have no idea all of a
sudden it's like wow it's an MDA
it's it's you know GP or it's these
things that we know from other fuels
having nothing to do with politics is
about smell is about olfaction so then
now and you know I want to be honest the
person that I coerced into doing the
statistics for this study was you know
this brilliant junior colleague of mine
and I said you know it's if it's a Miss
it's gonna be a big mess but nobody will
know but if it's a hit it's gonna be a
big hit he says you're really wacky rose
but I owe you so he never thought in a
million years it would work out so when
it did he was shocked right and by the
way he also threw up when he smelled
190c was a liberal guys smelling
conservative guy but these these every
single one of those factors with one of
them is related to taste that's why I'm
going there but the other ones are
really related to smell and so the
question that we really started with is
how is it that people don't know they're
selecting on politics but the people
where there's really long term
successful mating are selecting on
politics what's really going on is D
selection and so what is making you
deselect and it's these you know
unconscious automatic things because
we're not smart but evolution is
brilliant right we're talking about
neuro computational capacity over
millennial time and it knows you're
stupid you're going to do things
sexually that aren't in your best
interest all right but it also knows
that it can make you a little smarter
and it only has to do it at a nanogram
to increase you know survival over
millennial time and it does it by making
it not hard you just kind of don't smell
good to me so the other capacity the
other thing that this is related to why
we got this intuition is the original
work that was done on what on t-shirts
was really about the immune system so
everybody has an immune system the major
histocompatibility complex and there's a
very well-established work showing that
you that people don't like the smell of
people whose immune systems are similar
to theirs they like the smell of
somebody who's immune system is
different than theirs so why is that
well because pathogens work faster than
humans they have life cycles that are
much more you know we live to many years
and you know bacteria transform you know
24 hours so your kids are going to have
much more likelihood of survival if your
immune systems
are not overlapping if you have a
broader spectrum that's why there's um
you know this this kind of hidden
phenomenon of women who were on the pill
which affects these kinds of things and
you know then you go off the pill
because you want to get pregnant and all
of a sudden you actually really don't
like this other person you're with
that's a lot of immune system stuff so
you know evolution makes it in some
sense easy automatic inferential and so
the question for us was well if it can
do that on immune system it probably can
do it in political ideology but it's
hard to think about how that would
happen with a similar mechanism because
in one case you want somebody who's
really different than you want immune
system but really similar to you on
ideology but it's happening through the
same mechanism of smell right and
there's complicated reasons why we think
that works and you can read the paper
you won't want to but you can and you
know we go into it but but that was
basically the theoretical inspiration
and the empirical motivation for
undertaking alright so we're gonna we're
gonna have to stop there roses gonna
stick around please stick around keep
asking questions you're able to stay for
a bit right I want to ask you one more
quick thing actually let me skip to the
end tell us briefly about the book
that's here your co-editor of this book
right do you want to tell people this
book it's a little two three years old
and I edited it with my primary
collaborator Peter Tommy the person I
mentioned at the outset
who's at Penn State and it's a
collection of essays but we actually
wrote about a third of the book so we
wrote the theoretical chapter the
introduction the conclusion I wrote a
chapter on hormones but there's other
really major players who've also
contributed chapters there's a chapter I
love on chimps by Sarah Brosnan that
looks at you know the the way in which
we overlap with other primates on some
of these political factors you know she
she's the one who did that great studies
showing that chimps will go on hunger
strike if some of them get grapes and
some of them get cucumbers you know they
have a really strong sense of fairness
and equity sometimes better than humans
well always better than humans
and so you know there's there's a
sequence of other chapters in it I
suggested it because it's the most
comprehensive volume that combines a lot
of these different kinds of
contributions and like I said it's not
all mine but you know we did write about
a third of it and then the other
contributions I think are really pretty
strong as well great University of
Chicago right and we've got we've got
them in the back if you'd like to pick
one up tonight Rose this has been
fantastic thank you so much I want to
give you this is a long now challenge
coin is a little thank you for for
speaking for us tonight let's have a big
round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]
you